Speaker 1: Well, according to the anti-choice,
right.
If abortions are bad, then adoption is good.
And in fact, you have all these couples and
people with pictures where they say, we will
adopt your kids, don't abort, we will adopt
your kids.
So it's all good, right?
And abortion, increase adoption.
Everybody's happy.
Well, not so fast.
A radical, repugnant Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, is now saying that
non-biological parents are dangerous to children.
They are dangerous to children.
Well, hold on.
Abortion's bad, but adoption is also bad.
That doesn't make a lot of sense.
But that's what she's saying.
LGBTQ Nation Reporting Marjorie Taylor GREENE
calls non-biological parents a danger to children.
She doesn't like fake mom and fake dad.
Does she have a problem with adoptive parents?
Now, let's put aside for a second that her
buddy, Matt Gates, is like really an adoptive
parent to that kid Nelson.
I think his name is.
Maybe maybe that's a danger with Matt Gates.
Let's ignore that for a moment and see what
she had to say on her very strange podcast.
Speaker 4: So let's talk about children.
Children are in the greatest danger in America
today because of.
Speaker 1: Guns, right?
I mean, I'm sure she's going to say this there
more school shootings than ever.
Speaker 4: No family values are being destroyed.
Speaker 2: Oh.
Oh.
Speaker 4: The idea that mom and dad together
not not fake mom and fake dad, but biological
mom and biological dad can raise their children
together and do what's right for their children,
raising them to be to be confident in who
they are.
Their identity.
Their identity is their they're a child, you
know, made by God.
Right.
Let's talk about children.
Speaker 1: Nothing increases the confidence
of kids then being told their parents are
fake and not that good.
Right.
I mean, that'll really set kids up for success.
So the entire point of this is certainly homophobia
and probably transphobia as well.
So what Marjorie is really pointing to here
is gay parents, where maybe one parent is
biologically related to the child and one
is not adoptive couples.
Right.
Just like a gay couple or a lesbian couple.
And I guess because she says non-biological,
even heterosexual couples, I guess, are a
problem, because if it's not biological, it's
bad, according to Marjorie Taylor GREENE Certainly
transgender parents of all kinds.
I can only imagine even a biologically related
transparent Marjorie Taylor GREENE would say
is no good.
Step moms and step dads certainly must be
bad based on this idea.
Foster parents probably also terrible and
then guardians and caretakers of all kinds,
like when a kid dies or whatever, that that
they're all dangerous.
They're all extraordinarily dangerous.
So what do they want?
Do they want kids to suffer?
No.
They want moms to suffer.
That's really it.
I think the kids suffering, they're indifferent,
too.
But it's the moms.
I mean, listen, if you have.
Non.
What do they call it?
Non procreative sex.
And there's a pregnancy.
You've got to suffer as a parent.
That's really important.
Now, there's two sides to this stuff.
There's the cartoonish nuts with their podcasts,
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
But then there's the underlying policy ideas
that they want to push.
And you know where this is going?
They they're laying the groundwork.
They did it.
They they made it clear after Roe v Wade was
overturned by the Supreme Court.
Gay couples, they don't want to be able to
legally adopt.
They started with abortion.
Gay rights are on the chopping block.
They're already talking about overturning
the decision that banned bans on same sex
marriage, effectively legalizing effectively
legalizing gay marriage nationally.
It's all on the chopping block.
And meanwhile, consider the absurdity that
they say don't abort, will adopt your kids.
Well, but actually, when when kids are with
parents that aren't biologically related,
that's bad.
So is adoption good or bad?
Is it worse than abortion or better than abortion?
They don't want people to have abortions and
now they don't want the wrong people to abort.
If only there was a way to prevent unwanted
pregnancy before it even got to the point
of a pregnancy.
Then we would have a solution.
We have that, and that's also something that
they're against.
It's been widely studied.
And when you go to them, they talk in circles.
They talk past you.
They ignore.
They come up with, well, that's not actually
done the right way, because we know really
good study done out of Saint Louis.
You divide young people in particular into
groups where one group gets nothing.
This is your control group.
Another group gets free access to contraceptives.
Another group gets access to comprehensive
sex education.
And then your fourth group gets both the access
to the contraceptives and comprehensive sex
education.
Who do you think has the fewest unwanted pregnancies?
It's the last group, the group with the access
to contraceptives and the sex said, why don't
they want it?
Because of their strict father morality.
They have a belief that, okay, fine, maybe
that would work to reduce pregnancy.
But if you have non procreative sex, particularly
out of wedlock, as they love to say, isn't
that a beautiful term?
You're locked wedlock, then you deserve it.
You deserve you deserve to be forced to carry
a pregnancy to term.
That's fundamentally their belief.
It's not about, well, abortion, adoption,
whatever.
No, no, no, no.
It's about you got to behave the way they
believe Jesus wants you to behave, even if
you don't care about that particular religion
or any religion.
That's what they want.